[Musique]
oh
bonjour à tous ce numéro spécial de mode
d'emploi consacré à la troisième édition
de sky emploi en piste le job dating
saint quentinois organisée au vélodrome
national de son entreprise présente près
de cinq mille offres d'emploi à saisir
c'est parti
dans cette édition tv 60,18 se glisse
dans la peau d'un demandeur d'emploi
nous allons parcourir les différentes
étapes pour trouver un travail
nous commençons d'abord par élaborer et
construire notre cv avec l'aide d'un
spécialiste
nous allons ensuite nous préparer à
l'entretien d'embauché pour valoriser
notre profil et découvrir aussi des
astuces pour arriver détendu à un
entretien puis enfin nous rencontrerons
des représentants d'entreprises pour
connaître leurs besoins en recrutement
[Musique]
c'est le document essentiel dans une
démarche de recherche d'emploi le cv est
pour nous aider à construire le nôtre
nous rejoignons valentin pouillard
bonjour vous êtes co fondateur de cv
designer alors qu'est ce que vous pensez
de mon cv actuelle dans la démarche de
recherche d'emploi
alors nicolas ton cv déjà bien construit
des structures est néanmoins il ya quand
même quelques améliorations à apporter
la première chose le titre
j'ai vécu vingt bouteilles c'est un cv
pourquoi écrire cv sur un cv 500 évident
on va commencer par préciser un petit
peu quel type de poste tu va rechercher
en charge du marketing chargé le
marketing typiquement c'est ce qu'il
faudrait que faudrait écrire ici ensuite
dans la construction de ton cv la
première chose c'est que tu vas mettre
diplômes et formations en premier était
un professionnel dans le monde étudiant
hop je vais pouvoir déplacer et
effectivement j'ai déjà pas mal
d'expérience professionnelle dans
différentes entreprises ont bien sûr ok
valorise le est mêlé au premier c'est la
première chose que tu va vouloir
partager avec un recruteur c'est
l'expérience que tu acquise par le passé
ensuite il ya une section très important
du cv que tu as commencé à travailler et
ça c'est super choix qui néanmoins on va
se pencher dessus la partie compétences
les compétences elles se distinguent
entre quatre grandes catégories suivant
les compétences informatiques des
compétences opérationnelles dit métiers
et savoir être
sauf qu'ils ces choses qui sont assez à
la mode et enfin les compétences de
langue à ce sujet là il ya des codes à
respecter sur les compétences métiers
tels que tu les as fait tu a déterminé
des types de missions de tâches des
compétences opérationnelles que tu es
capable de monopoliser au sein
d'entreprises ça c'est super en revanche
sur la partie des langues films et des
barres de compétences est ce que tu
penses que ça met en valeur pour niveau
ce qui va intéresser l'entreprise c'est
pas de savoir si tu es un niveau expert
ou expert plus plus c'est simplement de
savoir si tech opérationnelle sur le
terrain on ça veut dire est ce que tu es
capable de tenir une conversation
est ce que tu vas passer des
certifications de langue typiquement si
tu as passé un toît quintaux fun ça va
donner une idée réelle et s'en sert de
ton niveau de langue c'est des
informations qu'il faut à tout prix
faire figurer sur le procédé est
d'accord concernant ce que vous avez dit
allez le savoir être les atouts vous
alors vous c'est plutôt à tous sur votre
site quand j'y suis allé c'était
vraiment distingué comme à tout ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut vraiment mettre
en avant parce que ça peut faire la
différence
absolument et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on appelle ça le bloc des
atouts les savoir-être
ça parle à certaines personnes ça ne
parle pas à d'autres c'est un atout pour
vous parce que lorsque vous avez 2 cv
qui présente un profil avec une
expérience et des compétences métiers
qui sont plus ou moins similaires la
différence vous la faites sur vos
compétences personnelles sur vos
attitudes nouveaux comportements
c'est la raison pour lesquelles ce bloc
a toute sa place sur son cv et qui
permet de renvoyer une image un peu plus
complète de votre profil professionnel
alors ça c'est sur le fond maintenant
sur la forme si on doit reconstruire
repenser mon cv
comment ça va se passer et vous avez
justement sur votre site internet on
peut vraiment l'aménager bien
correctement
donc le principe de ces designers fois
comme c'est de se créer un compte
gratuit dans lequel on va vous proposer
des modèles de cv regarde plus facile
pour transférer son cd que d'avoir une
base sur laquelle on va pouvoir très
facilement passer d'un modèle à l'autre
l'objectif c'est de vous faire gagner du
temps sur la mise en forme de votre cv
et de pouvoir y organiser les
informations pour donner un vrai sens
conformément à votre objectif
professionnel
donc on peut aussi changer complètement
la forme et être un peu plus savoir
ainsi les tendances 1 exactement ce que
tu me disais c'est que tu es sur un
poste de chargée de marketing le
marketing c'est de la communication
c'est donner envie aux gens de lire
avant de découvrir son produit sur le cv
ça va être la même chose donc donner
envie aux recruteurs de regarder ton cv
ça veut dire aussi mettre en valeur en
fonction de la forme quelque chose qui
est un petit peu plus séduisant
voilà est en fait finalement on peut
arriver à ce genre de choses et pourquoi
ce modèle là et mieux que celui
auparavant tout simplement parce que
lorsqu'on les met côte à côte
tu vas avoir un côté attractif attractif
pour l'oeil du recruteur donc notre
notamment lorsque tu va postuler à des
offres
tu as énormément de concurrents le
première étape c'est de donner
l'occasion recruteurs de lire et
découvrir ton cv ensuite c'est au niveau
de la lisibilité des informations mettre
en avant des contrastes par rapport aux
typologies police par rapport aux
couleurs ça va donner naissance de
lisibilité
tout en soulignant mais vraie force de
ton profil merci valentin brouillard et
maintenant que j'ai mon cv
direction la préparation à l'entretien
d'embauché
[Musique]
bonjour à tous
bonjour à s'employer bonjour ni colère
vous êtes bénévole pour l'association
rencontres pour l'égalité d'accès à
l'emploi et vous êtes un coach pour la
préparation à l'entretien d'embauché
exactement alors je recherche
actuellement un emploi dans le marketing
j'ai construit mon cv comment je dois
aborder un entretien d'embauché
alors pour moi il faut aborder
l'entretien d'embauché en fonction du
poste que l'on recherche
je vois que tu es tu cherches un poste
de chargé d'études en marketing soit il
est important de connaître
l'annnonce du cause sur lequel on
postule de repérer dans les missions du
poste de 3,4 iter clé
3 4 mo pertinents qui sont dans
l'annoncent et dans sa présentation
tu reprends au travers de ses
expériences ses trois ou quatre mots je
sais pas sur un poste de chargé d'études
en marketing
certainement qu'il est nécessaire
d'avoir le sens de l'organisation
l'important c'est que toi tu puisse
présenter une expérience une réussite
dans ton parcours professionnel où tu as
fait preuve de sens de l'organisation
le plus concret possible vraiment
rentrer dans les détails pour que ça
apparaisse vraiment comme vécu comme
vécu et comme une réussite
le principe même d'un recruteur pour moi
c'est que ce qu'un candidat
une personne a déjà su faire a déjà
réalisé elle sera le réaliser à nouveau
alors là vous donner justement vous
venez de donner l'exemple d'une personne
qui expérimentait mais imaginions que je
n'avais pas d'expérience et que
finalement j'étais faut uniquement sur
mes confères valoir mes diplômes
comment j'aurais fait ce que j'aurais pu
insister peut-être sûrement savoir être
sur ton savoir est sur tes expériences
autres pas forcément professionnel tu as
peut-être des passions tu as peut-être
fait du sport tu as peut-être ait été
dans des associations
et ça ça permet de valoriser des savoir
être
ça peut être la capacité relationnelle
l'écoutent l'organisation le travail en
équipe
voilà merci vincent employés pour ses
conseils et on va partir maintenant à la
rencontre d'une sophrologue qui va nous
conseiller sur la gestion du stress pour
aborder un entretien d'embauché
[Musique]
kla sophrologie c'est vraiment une
thérapie
un accompagnement pour que la personne
en fait puisse gérer ses émotions donc
face à un entretien effectivement puisse
se préparer également bientôt
mentalement pion par de la respiration
contrôlée de la visualisation positive
et de la détente musculaire pourra se
concentrer sur sa respiration
on va par exemple inspiré du positif
pour les rejeter du négatif
[Musique]
le stress bien entendu le stress le
manque de confiance en soi les problèmes
de mémoire
voilà d'un coup on sait plus comment
s'appelle on sait plus on a dit voilà
donc ça c'est des problèmes récurrents
[Musique]
l'idéal c'est de venir un mois au moins
minimum avant voire un sophrologue
puisque c'est tout un processus est ce
qu'on appelle une préparation mentale
on va d'abord au départ enlever tout ce
qui est négatif ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure
donc enlever le stress enlever les
croyances négatif ensuite on va aller
poser du positif donc installer la
sérénité développer la confiance en soi
le lâcher prise la concentration plein
de choses pour enfin arriver à son
objectif c'est-à-dire arriver encore en
mode warriors donc sur sur l'entretien
une autre voix peut être choisi par les
demandeurs d'emploi la formation
professionnelle entre 2018 et 2019
les entrées en formation par les
demandeurs d'emploi ont augmenté de 17%
nous nous sommes rendus à l'ifocop basée
à montigny le bretonneux des formations
proposées dans le tertiaire découverte
de cet établissement
déterminés les forces les faiblesses les
opportunités et les menaces d'une
société les critères de définition d'une
stratégie pour une entreprise
ces personnes en formation pour devenir
contrôleur de gestion suivent trois
jours de cours de stratégie ce qu'ils
doivent savoir faire c'est d'expliquer
de et les liens entre la stratégie et
l'opérationnel à travers les indicateurs
de performance les actions les
procédures les systèmes ancienne
directrice de supermarchés chaima
lemoine a décidé de faire une rupture
conventionnelle
après réflexion elle décide de suivre
une formation en fait je voulais
vraiment prendre un nouveau tournant
dans ma carrière avec mon expérience
professionnelle je voulais me
spécialiser en contrôle de gestion plat
je veux vraiment me spécialiser acquérir
les compétences par exemple sur excel
sur les différents outils qui vont me
permettre de donner des prêts qu aux
entreprises comptabilité marketing
ressources humaines ou développement web
l'institut ifo coop de montigny le
bretonneux propose 20 sessions de
formation par an dans des activités du
tertiaire quatre mois de cours quatre
mois en entreprise
près de 300 stagiaires sont accueillis
chaque année nous accueillons environ 80
% de demandeurs d'emploi et 20 % de
salariés sur le centre de montigny là
nous venons d'avoir des sorties sur
justement gestionnaire de paie et rh
on est à plus de 90%
ça veut dire que les stagiaires se voit
proposer un cdd ou un cdi dans leur
entreprise de stage
d'après les chiffres de pôle emploi plus
de sept cent quatre-vingt-dix mille
demandeurs d'emploi sont entrés en
formation en 2019
maintenant que nous avons notre nouveau
cv que nous nous sommes préparés à
l'entretien d'embauché partons à la
rencontre des employeurs pour connaître
leurs différents besoins
nous on recrute essentiellement des
chauffeurs poids lourds pour des portes
voiture on a aussi une partie gestion de
parc où on recrute beaucoup de
préparateurs automobiles
on recherche énormément d'un cadran au
niveau des terrains des conducteurs
travaux des techniciens aussi au niveau
des terrains et aussi des ingénieurs
qu'attendez vous d'un candidat lorsque
vous le recevez en face de vous alors
quand le reçoit on attend qu'il soit
c'est clair et précis sur ses
motivations et sur son projet
professionnel de l'envi qu'il nous
montre qu'il a envie qu'il est intéressé
par notre offre qu'il s'est préparé à
cette offre préalablement à savoir à se
poser les bonnes questions pourquoi
elles m'intéressent qu'est ce que je
peux apporter comment je me projette
[Musique]
c'est la forme de ce numéro merci de
nous avoir suivis retrouvez cette
émission en ripé sur notre site internet
ou sur l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]